today i wanted to talk to reggie watts
about as many mind-blowing conan
[Applause]
[Music]
appearances
thank you and then wrap it up with one
that i think was
extra special for me a lot of work goes
into a short late night stand-up set
join me jp buck as i spotlight the
comedians who came up with some of my
favorite coin sets
this is the setup please welcome our
really good friend
reggie watts
[Music]
there was a point in 2005
where i moved back to new york left the
industry for a little bit
and i was on the train and i ran into a
kid named greg who i used to babysit for
and he said to me he said you have got
to go
see this guy reggie watts i saw him at
pianos
it's insane and one night i was at
invite them up and here is
reggie watts the moby dick i felt like i
was searching for
i i had like i felt like i'd left the
business but like you were sort of the
person that
i felt kind of pushed me back to move to
la again to get back into comedy
and i was like when i came back i was
armed with the
knowledge that reggie watts exists oh
wow that's that's crazy that's cool
in 2011 you were backstage in the green
room and camille nanjiani was back there
and there was a joke that you two
i don't know who said it or her
responder who added to it but there was
a ups what can brown do for you joke
that you guys made
you went out on stage you did a song
that was about brownness
and you it was just something i guess
that was buried in your head from an
hour before then you had a song about it
on stage yeah that makes sense
this is a song that i wrote uh about
brownness i do remember
camille being there and uh and it was
just so cool to have him out there and
when i was doing that
you know that particular song um you
know
knowing that he was out there was it was
kind of awesome feeling i remember
yeah every show was so different every
song like they're just like their
their fleeting moments i feel yeah i
mean they're
you know it's just the nature of
improvisation um and
i i love that about it you know i i
loved uh
you know going on stage and doing these
whatever they were
in that moment and knowing that ah you
know unless they were recorded
there they go um you know these days i'm
trying to
you know do something with those
recordings but i mean i'm trying to
record
things and try to see if i can use them
in other ways but but back then
you know performing live so much i just
i didn't have the
you know the forethought of bringing
recorders and stuff you know i was just
like yeah
it's just fine it doesn't matter i'll
just do it and
people will hopefully like it
[Music]
me
one more time one more time
that needs to be a song i call i in my
ipod i have it filed as warming the
sugar
i don't even know if that's what you
want to make i love it
and as we used to say it's like warming
the sugar it's like
yes indeed that's crazy that's that's
amazing well
yeah what a trip to see that that song
makes you so happy with that when i hear
it yeah such a cool like throwback
you know the vibe um just feels like
classic entertainment you know i mean it
feels like something that could have
happened in the last
four decades flash forward to 2014 i
really wanted you to work with one
guitarist that you didn't know before
and just have you come together and see
what you could come up with
you remember this do you remember me
like trying to beg you a few times and
you're like no no no
no no oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it was like
such a i was like i don't know man but
then like uh
yeah last minute i'm just like yeah sure
and so travis stever
of cohedon cambria like his guitar solo
is in the rock band video game that's
how
guitarist is yeah right and so he
was in new york and he agreed and i i
couldn't get a hold of you so i said
just get on a plane
we'll make it work so he jumps on a
plane and i wake up
sunday morning and i get i get a
voicemail
and it's billy gibbons from zz top all
right
billy f gibbons bfg your favorite buddy
from the cz
child speaking he had just gone down a
rabbit hole with his wife and
watched maybe six or seven of your
videos
and he said he was getting in his car
and they were driving to l.a
and he'll see me tomorrow morning so now
wow now there's a second guitarist and
you kind of
have to work with him because he's like
one of the greatest guitarists of all
time
so yeah this is all coming back it's
crazy
[Music]
in rehearsal various different
rehearsals the song was about different
things
yes i think in the last rehearsal you
used
you said something about a horse just
off hand mentioned a horse
and then suddenly the song became
four and a half minutes from the story
of the perspective of a horse
yeah yeah that's true yeah i mean
it's just stupid you know like it's just
like
stuff happens and it's so dumb but you
know and it's
there's just i always got off on the
idea of having
you know serious musicians you know
uh dedicated to you know
performing a certain way and and a
certain vibe in a certain zone
and then um and then and then playing
off of that in an absurd way but like
doing it really since
relatively sincerely but it's obviously
about something very simple and absurd
and so it made sense that you know the
song is kind of a country sounding so i
was like oh yeah i'll just make it about
horses
[Music]
there's a horse i knew a long time ago
i used to run around like horses
sometimes do
when i heard the windy of the wind above
i used to wonder what that horse was
thinking of
[Music]
you keep trotting up
you keep galloping
you keep doing things that horses are
known to do
but i see the way you
[Music]
and i feel
has there ever been a more beautiful
country song about a horse i don't know
i mean there's a horse with no name but
that's america and i don't really think
this country but
no no that's not country it's america
it's funny it's like it came together so
quick and
you know and here we are doing it you
know it's it's um
it's it's cool i mean it's like it's so
it definitely fulfills one of the dreams
you know that i
that i had you know at the time which is
to be able to come up with an idea very
quickly with people and then just like
put it together and just suddenly it's
happening but it's
you know plus the idea of it being a
little bit
kind of more serious in a way you know
like it it's
it's still funny but it's but i'm trying
to be
as sincere in that moment as as possible
um it's funny that these two great
musicians too were
kind of a little nervous which i which i
thought was you know because
because these guys were obviously like
here's the song let's rehearse it you
know over and over again and like we
barely like ran through it like maybe
three times like the structure of it
and so it was kind of everybody was like
okay well we hope this works that was
the whole spirit of it it was it was
great
what billy gibbons is doing next like
billy gibbons is
like i said one of the greatest guitars
of all time has
iconic songs and he is just sitting in
the back
and letting you guys do your thing and
he just wants to add a little like a
little flourish
and he's got his steel guitar and he
just sort of does a little bit of like
texture to it
like right here listen to this i love it
[Music]
it feels like jazz a little bit here
yeah yeah it does yeah it is
yeah it's interesting that's that's
funny absolutely
i remember him doing that that's i was
like oh okay he's gonna do that okay
cool
[Laughter]
did you tie the horse up to a post
[Music]
because if you don't know it's live just
walk away
did you remember to give hay and water
to it if you don't
the chances are your horse just might
not survive the night
and every time i try to put myself
in a horse's shoes
it hurts my feet baby and i just want to
know
does it hurt when you run over different
forms of terrain and when you see
that cloud cover breaking something
coming down
do you need to know how much it can
really
break
[Music]
feel the power in your tail in your main
main
i'm just like watching it going like oh
yeah this is me like trying to figure
out where it's going to go next you know
and like uh it was definitely a little
bit more nerve-wracking than usual for
sure because you know you have these
other musicians on stage you know
they've never
played that i've never i've never played
with and so
i had a response i felt like it was
slightly responsible to making sure they
were
you know everything was like together um
yeah so that was
that was very that was interesting it's
definitely a different kind of
[Music]
performance
you feel like it might change
someday and you'd know
that it would carry us away
wanna reach out but my hand might be
dangerous cause
[Music]
the song is also very kind of like led
zeppelin
there's like a zeppelin vibe to it which
is kind of
interesting that i'm just kind of
noticing and when you know that
it's gonna be a great day
when you're galloping to the edge of a
cliff with a buffalo used to jump
and if you
[Music]
i gotta know
[Laughter]
[Music]
here
marty yu says he is an american treasure
i wish my mind had two percent of
reggie's interestingness
except i couldn't wear all the sweaters
as i am a sweater
that's saying a lot coming from a
sweater i mean you even knew that
sweater's possessed consciousness but uh
it's uh
it's great to hear that you know all
forms of material reality are responding
favorably to what i do
targeted apologies for mispronouncing
this
i feel like all the audience members
were scared to laugh because they
thought he was singing real jazz
come on white people i wouldn't befall
it on anybody any one
type of person to not get or get it it's
really
i think it's about individual experience
at that point wallace wahoo says
i'm not even sure what just happened but
i could watch slash listen to reggie
watts for hours
that's sweet that's sweet that's yeah
that's the feeling you know that's what
i hope
it's like i can do dumb random things
and
you know people will still want to hear
that for some
strange reason
thank you so much this is awesome to go
down memory lane so it just
yeah stirs up a lot of great feelings
it's great to see you
and i mean i miss i really do miss being
able to do every
everything that we used to do but at the
same time i'm so happy for
how busy you've become how successful
you've become and it's
it's just fun to watch and uh and also
it's also fun to kind of reminisce about
these old
old experiences you know the whole
experience with conan and the whole crew
i mean that definitely
that helped me get me to where i am so
you know i'm always eternally grateful
always so you know it's cool it took a
chance on a weird dude from montana
well you're part of our weird family
always
yes